on this episode I talk about what I
would do with crush it if I wrote it
again anchor the voice app and the music
industry
[Music]
[Music]
this
Gary B I want to write an article about
why I can't do the cm job at vaynermedia
like literally I want the title to be
like literally I'm not joking I would
not be hired for the entry-level job at
vaynermedia cuz it's true I don't think
I could be right now I don't think I
could pass learn phrase I know
Russian could not pass the grammar test
you didn't think I gonna pass it I mean
I definitely like learn grammar do you
think it's true that you can get higher
now yeah that's like I get it right so
like my first week there really write a
Content calendar and I was like and then
my person even Gary he was like so what
it comes like [ __ ] with my money India
funny how things work out
all right let's do it ready 183
everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode one 83 of the ask gary
vee yeah we're on a real rally right
four straight days which is woo and like
real episodes I mean big shout-out to
the community you know that your
comments are my oxygen many and I mean
many people across Facebook YouTube and
Instagram claiming that 182 was the best
episode in the history of the askgaryvee
show and that makes sense to me because
it definitely had a different vibe it
did get very deep there was a
really talking about the book and
answers the first and last one you saw
that I have to do a book end kind of
thing India so people made some comments
about you let's get into the show
Kareem yo f Kirino asked how do you
check your building VM in a way that
would thrive beyond your charisma as a
CEO how do you build great successors uh
that's a great question I think it comes
in dailyvee 15 you'll see me in the dirt
I think one of the things that's very
confusing about me is I do live parallel
lives I do live a life where I'm a
outgoing personality a lightning-rod of
a personality a charismatic character
the basis of this question we have the
show we have dailyvee we have all my
content I engage them on TV I mean you
know I'm actually keeping myself off of
TV but here we go with the new book
coming out dr. oz right Fox and Friends
in the morning CNN with Don Lemon like
I'm gonna be out there right
magazines things of that nature so you
know with all that being said one thing
that people have struggled with
quantifying is that I am working 18
hours a day which allows me to in
essence live two lives I'm living two
lives
I'm putting the hours in as I was as if
I was a personal brand and abundant and
a tastemaker and an author and a speaker
and a personality but I'm equally at
scale running this organization I you
know it's very easy for this company to
uh to run it and be structured and be
set up for success without me I mean I
don't even think my 18 I just met the
AT&T client you know like like like
there's so much business going on that
has nothing to do with me that is set up
by the well compensated very senior
twenty years into their career
executives that roll around here I mean
they're there's 600 people deep here's
an actual fact Stefon let's get into a
little bit of editing here no joke
I need I need I need 21 seconds of
b-roll of the three floors in New York
man
[Music]
people are working here this is a real
organization I'm I'm the CEO vaynermedia
I happen to moonlight as Gary Vee yeah
actually there's a good one right so
like how do I do it I built the I mean I
don't know the last 18 hours of my
meetings have been completely
organizational and operational meanings
for vaynermedia I I so understand and
never get upset why people don't believe
that's to be true or AJ is doing it like
they don't know and they don't know and
dailyvees been the only beginning of
optics to people to know that I'm
actually doing the work Daniel asked
well people use anchor as an alternative
podcasting platform I do believe that
has a potential I'm very excited about
anchor I put anchor directly into only 5
seconds old but I already put it
directly into the category of like I
need to keep an eye on this mainly
because and I don't know if we'll ever
find this I don't know Stefan maybe when
you're bored you know which is never
like but if you ever come across some
two thousand seven eight nine videos I
talked a lot about audio Twitter I don't
know if I ever even put it out publicly
you know unusually I'm like identity I
don't know but I've been obsessed with
the idea of audio Twitter for a long
time
what's that I did say going back to
voice somewhere yes please think let's
find that I've been obsessed with voice
for a long time it's a it's an important
platform it's one of the ways we
communicate it's why podcasting is
reimburse and I do think anchor or
something like it has the potential to
become a very important platform I'm a
hundred percent like the article that we
just wrote going to use anchor for my
thoughts and then basically we're gonna
write articles about it so that people
follow me anchor well he you know be fun
for them to see what the translation is
from how we act like talk about really
exposing our process I'm literally gonna
instead of memos and sending to you
start doing them on anchor people here
all the silliness and how I correct
myself and they'll see how we transcribe
or how much we don't transcriber
much grammar you have to deploy against
me and so I think it will absolutely be
a podcast play for a lot of people I've
considered it here I considered actually
recording this right now like literally
right now I might even record the next
question as an effect I will like right
like this is all going very weird so yes
do I have to hold it down do I have to
hold it down when I hit record oh it's
only 2 minutes - and you do have to hold
it down yeah oh yeah you could probably
do cheerier you probably it's really
well done I love the onboarding Josh
Helman big shadow you're right about the
onboarding is tremendous so yeah I think
I think you know now it's only 2 minutes
though yeah so I guess no it's now my
answer is I'm like playing with the app
you know I think um but I think it's a
great promotion tool for 2 minutes as a
gateway drug to your actual podcasts
especially cuz you put a URL in the post
I test that already like when you put
the additional stuff said it's really
neat I'm enjoying like there's nothing
more fun than like it's kind of like
going to school in the first day of
sixth grade and there's two new kids in
school that was weird hanker that was
very weird you know it's and you know
and one of them you have a crush on
right you're like it was Sally so pretty
you know and so like there's a new app
it's interesting its voice it's a space
I've been paying attention to for a long
time and waiting for this moment we'll
see what happens with it's very early
let's not you know when something like
peach or anchor I mean these are for
hundreds of a second old but I'm paying
attention to it in the way I'm paying
attention to peach and other things
let's not get it it's not musically yet
and it's definitely not snapchat yet
Chris Drucker
I know Christian well I think I'm doing
this podcast soon hey what's up Gary
Chris Ducker here over in the
Philippines look man you know you've had
so many great book launches before
you've got another one coming up I'm
sure it's gonna be a massive success I'm
curious to know from one author to
another what actually happens post
launch do you carry on with your
marketing team pushing the book out
there or do you just let the internet
the readers social and Amazon reviews
take over to continue the marketing
thanks for the insights brother
great question Creston really enjoyed
our time we spent in San Diego he's a
really good guy I'm excited to do his
podcast Chris for me I usually wait to
the New York Times comes out and to see
where it lands would crush it it became
wildfire and went on Thank You economy I
really the second it came out I stopped
up it really just became CEO vaynermedia
with Jab Jab I continued it through for
a little bit and with with askgaryvee
I'm doing heavy promotion now I'll do it
in March I'll do it in April there's a
little bit of May events different
things like I I'm funny feeling
askgaryvee the book is going to be huge
and I'll tell you why multiple people
now who have the galley copy who are
reading it who are either so not full of
[ __ ] that they would tell me it's suck
there was good end or have no interest
in giving a crap about me or number
three don't even know who I am are
giving such intense good feedback and it
makes sense because it's it's the
collection of my best work this show we
edit it by the way just just to clear it
up it is 1,000% not a transcribe from
this show like I reinsert all the
questions in new form
there was a baseline but I didn't I
didn't let any word-for-word be the
answer I added to it I changed my mind
I changed my mind between the book in
the audio book then one of the things
that I feel bad about is people gonna
fundamentally that give a crap at all
I'm gonna have to buy both cuz they're
different and I actually don't even know
if I gave different answers I'm dying to
see the first person actually sits and
sees what discrepant and somebody's
really hardcore on opening day please
read the book in parallel to the
audiobook and see call me out on the 2
or 3 where there's a discrepancy will
use askgaryvee
maybe we use askgaryvee episode 200 to
clear up all clarifications between the
book and the audiobook so so Kris to
answer your question i I'm gonna let it
take over because I actually think I'll
probably you know foot off the pedal in
in May 3 months you know March is
intense
April is solidly intense I'll do some
stuff in May the only thing I can see
happening though is I do think there
might be some fire a lot of you are
buying a you know with the super 8
coming up on the 23rd
is that a week from today no from a week
from today I'll be in here for eight
hours with the big contest and all that
I have a feeling a lot of you are gonna
buy eight books which means you're gonna
give seven books away or six or sell
them on eBay do your thing but I think
that's gonna create new people they're
gonna read the book I think it's fired
they're gonna start watching the show I
see word of I feel more word of mouth
potential in this book than anything
else and so if it's on fire fire I'll
ride that wave because I think you have
to ride waves and so I'll be very
exhausted if that's true cuz I have a
lot of work to do besides the book some
reactionary Chris is the punch line like
everything else I do that was a little
insight for all of the other that's
always the answer
I'm always tasting and day-trading and
adjusting and prepared for anything at
all times always period like an actual
tool or Oh a tool Oh got it
until asked hey Gary if you're a writing
crusher today what would you change in
it well I think I'm gonna be able to do
that for your tool I am debating between
perfectly parented and crushed it as my
next book and so what I would do is I
would update it I would call it so it's
gonna called crushed it I already know
it's gonna be go crushed it and I'm
gonna interview a hundred of you I'm
probably not I'm gonna do it I might
even give them for the first time with
help from India or whoever because I
don't that's just a lot of time so I'm
gonna have somebody help me interview a
hundred people that read crush it and
change their lives I'm gonna add
commentary on top of it I'll figure out
a way to do a private stream with those
hundred people and talk to them and what
have you and then I'll write the back
half of that book will be okay that's
what I talked about a no.9 YouTube
Twitter Facebook here's twenty seventeen
right musically snapchat it you know
Instagram anchor peach you know
after-school what-have-you but there's
so many ways to continue and then really
I think askgaryvee has a lot of I think
ask I mean one of the first reviews I
saw people are sniffing out that
askgaryvee is in a weird way a disguised
crushed it there's a lot of information
for people who are watching this show
and in the world to elevate their
business or their
personal brand from a $30,000 thing to a
$300,000 thing if they actually pay
attention to the religion and the
tactics of this book but I'm gonna go
even deeper very hardcore personal brand
if you want to be America's gardener if
you want to make money singing if you
are this that and the other thing this
is what you have to do tactically and
religiously that will be crushed it so
what would I do I would update it I
wrote that book in 2009 that means I
wrote it in 8 it would be you know eight
nine years and that's a lot of time a
lot of things have changed people still
crush crush it is still the best-selling
book and so it's motivational and so
that's why it's timeless but a lot of
the advice can be outdated at this point
so I'm excited about writing crushed it
last one this is a nice man I'm gonna
really could this be the new golden era
another golden era could be right these
are really I'm gonna very like mature a
masculine mode Triple M mode when looks
cool what's up Gary my name's language
from Newton at Sydney Australia and
might I've got a question in response to
one of your snapchats I in regards to
the Grammys where you said the market is
the market stop crying my out when I
want to know if you were in charge of
the music industry where would you take
it if I was in charge of a music
industry or let's say what everybody's
crying about if I'm a if I'm a music
label or a music artist the first thing
I would take it is to a mental place
where I realized it can't be 1964
anymore like sorry sorry that you make
all your money on records it's not 1990
anymore it's just not I would accept
that like like I love look music is such
an important part of our culture that I
mean I was by the way the snap that I
did actually you know what
beautiful I'm going to save it right now
stuff on and send it to you we're really
in production value these days tea rocks
really freaking affected me I don't like
it the market is
market right there it is same a song is
worth what the market pays for it period
the markets the market stop crying you
know the old dude from the Grammys went
on is like kids don't steal music like
you know he's been doing this for years
right like there's a song worth the
penny know and everybody claps a song's
worth what the market pays for it like
nobody forced you to make deals with the
screaming companies like I hate this you
know there was a story once that Groupon
was bad because and if you can find this
headline Stephon I want to get into some
editing here throw it up right now
that Groupon is bad because a woman went
out of business because she sold too
many cupcakes and a deal I don't know if
you remember this India Groupon you're
bad why Groupons bad for small business
because this one woman made an offer and
too many people took her up on it and it
put her out of business
Ruben's fall that's your [ __ ] fault
Sally you're running your business like
it's little Chris right and so like to
go up and be like is a song worth a
penny when your Studios record labels
are like when you mean the deal with the
streaming companies is crazy the market
is the market and so the bottom line is
if you're great at music and just music
and you're not good at performing and
you don't want to hustle new shows and
if you're not charismatic and if you
don't have all the other things your
world has changed
sorry just like if you're six foot and
white and not athletic you could have
played basketball on 1915 actually how
it seems is did you get that camera work
in the beginning like did you catch us
did the part where me and you talked
about not being able to be a cm at
Vayner the part where india said I don't
think I could be a cm at Vayner today I
get it I get but you but it's the point
it's the point like of course you could
but like the market at vaynermedia
changed like markets change and like
you're gonna force India to buy a 15
dollar CD like what do you want like I
get it and if India's compelled enough
for that indie band or retro or emo or
doubt if she rolls hip-hop whatever she
likes country what
if they bring you value stuff on whose
music do you buy if anybody's do you buy
anybody there you go J Cole clearly he's
done something that makes you want to
buy it I know J Cole Congrats J Cole you
made your 97 cents or four bucks off
Stefon I guess you did that through your
swag your lyrics your songs how you roll
like all the other burials besides just
a song right that's that that's just the
market and I'm sorry that you don't like
it and I'm sorry that it used to be
great let me tell you that a lot of
other things that used to happen I don't
know everything like you used to let
your kids go outside and not scared of
you kidnapped used to not have to worry
about aids you used to have to not worry
about guns in schools like shooting
people every minute
used to have to not worry about oil
disappearing as we get close to neutral
oil price like you still have to not
worry about everything but you just have
to worry about the Soviet Union blowing
you up you as though you used to have to
worry about like not being able to cure
any version of cancer like its evolution
people sorry that music is not the way
it used to be sorry that it's evolved
you know I don't see anybody going crazy
for bookstores and got you to the
bookstore guy going up there my god
sorry buddy Amazon came sorry
like nobody's super duper duper sad for
calves the consumers right not common or
Beyonce got it so it is what it is yes
it's important yes music really matters
yes yes guess what when you were making
all that money music in 1955 the best
baseball players in America and football
players in America had jobs in the
summer because they didn't get paid a
lot but guess what happened America
decided they really loved football and
that means that they got more leverage
over time and now they get paid a lot of
money and they don't need side jobs in
the summer anymore but maybe it flipped
and now you use it should actually have
to hustle and you made me actually have
to like your fans and you may actually
have to take selfies and you may
actually have to do live events and you
may have to do things that's just the
way it is period market dynamics
everybody's affected by them always and
forever
I want an article in that title if you
music industry alright something else
meaning question of the day when have
you been affected by market conditions
pro or con you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
[Music]